[MUSIC PLAYING]
LYZELLE CARREON: Thanks,
everyone, for coming.
We'll get started.
I'm Lyzelle, I'm part of
the Asian Google Network.
And I'm here with Chris Cheung,
who was born and raised here
in New York.
He's a renown chef.
He is the owner of East
Wind Snack Shop in Brooklyn
and is now also
the Executive Chef
Partner of the newly-opened
Tansuo restaurant in Nashville.
And he's obviously the
cook of the delicious food
that you're eating,
which is the--
CHRIS CHEUNG: It's cucumber
salad with crispy shallots
and sesame.
It's with chicken and vinegar.
LYZELLE CARREON: And
also, in Truck Pit,
if you guys haven't
gone there already,
there are the baos, his--
CHRIS CHEUNG: So yeah, we do,
at East Wind, a pork belly bao.
So it's slow braised
pork belly with pickles.
Yeah, we have that at East
Wind, so I had the chefs here
do it on their own for
Google, so it's pretty cool.
LYZELLE CARREON: Yeah.
So we can all eat that
after if you have already.
Awesome!
So thanks for being here, Chris!
CHRIS CHEUNG: Thanks
for having me.
LYZELLE CARREON: We're excited
to get to know you better
and learn more about your
success in the food scene.
CHRIS CHEUNG: Yeah, anything
I can help you with on that,
sure.
LYZELLE CARREON: OK.
So let's jump right in.
Let's talk about East Wind
and the East Wind Snack Shop.
What inspired you to
open the restaurant?
CHRIS CHEUNG: OK, so when I was
a kid, I grew up in Chinatown.
And in Chinatown, there
were these little coffee
shops, these little tea houses
that really served the working
class of Chinatown--
so lots of lunches,
meat over rice, baos,
dumplings-- and that's
what I lived off of.
And so when the space
came up for East Wind,
it was so reminiscent
of those coffee
shops and those teahouses, it
brought me back to my childhood
and then I was inspired
to kind of recreate
a modern version of that.
And so that's how that took
off, so that was pretty cool.
LYZELLE CARREON: And East Wind's
been open for about two years,
now?
CHRIS CHEUNG: Yeah, a
little over two years.
LYZELLE CARREON: What
do you love about owning
the restaurant and cooking?
CHRIS CHEUNG: Well, when
you own your own place,
you get to obviously
call your own shots.
You can forge a path from
your own creative juices
and really control your
own destiny on that.
It's also a really cool
feeling when it's successful.
So that's one of the benefits,
because doing business in New
York is extremely difficult.
LYZELLE CARREON: What are
your most popular dishes?
CHRIS CHEUNG: So we
have a few dishes.
It's a very small menu, it's
about eight items on the menu.
And so when I first started
cooking at East Wind,
we did dumplings--
and we still do--
and we get a lot of great
things said about our dumplings.
So I spent the first--
I still do it, I chase
the perfect dumpling.
So I try to cook every dumpling
with the technique in mind
to make sure that that
dumpling is great,
and that goes from everywhere
from making our own dough,
grinding our own meat,
folding those doughs by hand
from scratch every day,
doing the dumplings by batch
every day so we only
have enough by par--
and when it runs
out it runs out--
and we cook each one to order.
So a lot of work goes into the
juicy pork dumplings, which
is probably my best seller.
The dry aged beef pot
stickers are pretty well
received by the
critics in New York.
And then I do this pork
belly bun, which I told you
you'll have a little later on.
LYZELLE CARREON:
Do you think you've
got the perfect dumpling?
CHRIS CHEUNG: You know, cooking
is variable from day to day
and sometimes you get
that one that you cook,
that one that was
like, that's so great,
but it's fleeting, right?
So then you serve it and
it's gone, and you know,
you left it to keep cooking.
So that's I call it
chasing, it's always
difficult to keep doing it
under variable conditions,
but it's about giving it your
best effort every single time.
LYZELLE CARREON: And do you
have any personal favorites?
CHRIS CHEUNG: Yeah.
So the juicy pork
dumpling, like you said,
when we first started it, it
went through a few iterations
and I just made a decision to
really just cook everything
from scratch and do everything
by the day, and it really,
really makes a difference.
You get proud of the product
when you see it comes out
the way you want it.
LYZELLE CARREON: So if
you don't know Chris,
he's pretty much a TV star now.
Can you tell us about some
of the shows you've been on?
CHRIS CHEUNG: Yeah,
so, you know--
TV star?
I'm trying.
LYZELLE CARREON: So modest.
CHRIS CHEUNG: I happened
to get a lot of--
there's my mic.
Sorry, guys.
Just leave that there.
I happen to had the pleasure to
be on a few really good shows.
Martha Stewart's show,
was a judge on "Chopped."
I was on one of the early
food competition shows done
by the Food Network, and that
was "The Next Great Chef,"
and I got to battle
Sean Brock, who
is a nationally acclaimed
chef who happens to actually
have a restaurant in
Nashville as well,
so it's going to be cool meeting
him later on down the line.
I've also done the
Anthony Bourdain
show, "No Reservations,"
which was really, really cool.
LYZELLE CARREON: Is that the
most interesting and memorable?
CHRIS CHEUNG: That one
happens to be the one that's
helped my career the most.
So Anthony Bourdain
is a mega star
and I had the pleasure of taking
him on a tour of all three
Chinatowns in New York City.
One in Flushing,
dim sum in Brooklyn,
and then Hop Kee in Manhattan,
in Manhattan's Chinatown.
And so yeah, it is really,
really cool to have been--
think I did four spots
over two episodes
and then helped them on
another episode, which
I was behind the camera.
Yep.
LYZELLE CARREON:
I personally want
to know, what's it like
to work with Anthony?
What's he really like?
CHRIS CHEUNG: OK,
so Anthony Bourdain
is the same exact guy off
camera as he is on camera.
He's very sharp witted.
And the work involved
in doing his show
is the easiest thing you'll
ever do if you ever do food TV.
You sit with him, you drink,
you get drunk, you eat a lot,
and then you talk about food.
And then he cracks his jokes.
And then you get on
national TV for doing it,
so it was pretty cool.
LYZELLE CARREON: Nice.
So when you're not in
front of the camera,
what's a day in the
life of Chris' life?
CHRIS CHEUNG: OK, so lately,
it's been pretty hectic.
I have two restaurants.
So East Wind is
located in Brooklyn
and it happens to be three
blocks away from my house.
So over my career, it has been
the quickest, easiest commute
that I've ever had
to work, and we all
know, living and working in New
York, how crazy that can be.
So my next move is to open a
restaurant 1,000 miles away.
And so it's a lot of going
back and forth from restaurant
to restaurant, heading
to the airport,
and then the rest of the
day, the rest of the time
is trying to spend as much
time with my family as I can.
LYZELLE CARREON:
So speaking about
interesting and memorable, tell
us about the Asian Food Mafia.
That's a memorable, catchy name.
What is it?
CHRIS CHEUNG: OK, so Asian
Food Mafia is a group of chefs
that I've formed together.
We all are Asian, we all own
or run our own restaurants.
Currently, the
roster goes from me,
Doron Wong of Northern Tiger,
Chef Bao Bao of Baoburg,
Medwin Pang of Hunger Pang,
Lien Lin of Bricolage,
Pichet Ong, Jonathan
Wu of Fung Tu
is pretty much the
core of our group.
And we basically get
together once a month,
hang out, eat, drink,
rant about the industry,
talk shop and go over problems.
And then we've also started to
get into some community events
as well.
LYZELLE CARREON: What
kind of community events?
CHRIS CHEUNG: So we're trying
to shape the way Asian food is
perceived, especially
in New York,
and trying to do our best,
our thing for the community.
We've done one event for the
Museum of Chinese in America
and we did a panel discussion
about the past, present,
and future of Asian cuisine.
And that was to help the museum
as well as get our word out.
And we're doing
an upcoming event
where we're going to have
a collaborative dinner,
so watch out for that.
I'm really excited to
cook alongside of all
those great chefs,
and we're going
to do it at Fung Tu in
the Lower East Side.
So probably in a
couple of months,
we'll make that announcement.
LYZELLE CARREON: Oh, cool.
So with the Asian
Food Mafia, what
are some of the challenges
you and the Mafia
have faced as Asian
American chefs starting
a business in New York?
And running a
business in New York?
CHRIS CHEUNG: Yeah,
so there's lots
of challenges to running
businesses in New York.
I'm not too sure if
it's indicative of just
Asian American chefs
per se, running
a small business in New
York is extremely difficult.
It's extremely hard and New
York does not make it easy,
so, you know, the saying goes,
if you could make it here,
you can make it anywhere.
That's 100% true.
There are so many things that--
owning a business in New York--
they make you go through.
A lot of it may be
unnecessary, but overall,
it's really, really
difficult. So as Asian chefs,
together, we're able to
tackle some of the challenges.
Like staffing, if one of
us is looking for cooks,
we can always go to
each other and see
if there's any referrals out.
If my dishwasher
doesn't come in,
I can always ask to
borrow a dishwasher
from one of the other chefs.
So strength in numbers
makes it a lot easier
for us to get just
the basics of the day.
You know?
LYZELLE CARREON:
Earlier you mentioned,
when you were talking,
that some places don't want
an Asian kind of restaurant?
CHRIS CHEUNG: Well,
some of the challenges
happen to be on a little
bit of a higher scale.
I've, as an Asian American
opening Chinese restaurants
or Asian restaurants, I've
encountered real estate
companies who tell me their
landlords do not want Asian
restaurants or Chinese
restaurants for whatever
reason-- the smell of food--
anywhere near their
community or their block, so
it's really tough to
hear when that happens.
But I take it on the chin.
Sometimes the best
deal is no deal.
I don't want to be anywhere
where I'm not wanted,
and so I'll look
at other options.
But still, it is a tough thing
to hear when you hear something
like that for sure.
LYZELLE CARREON: Going
into a little bit more
of your community
involvement, how--
or just the community
at large, how have you
seen the Chinese or
Asian-American community
changing over the years since
you've been and raised here.
CHRIS CHEUNG: It's changed
and grown immensely.
When I was a kid
growing up, there
was one community that
represented Asia in general,
and that was
Chinatown Manhattan--
Mott Street, L Street,
Bayard Street--
and it started to
grow from there.
As I got a little
older, the joke
was, Chinatown was kind of
taking over all of downtown New
York, right?
After September 11th,
that kind of changed
and Chinatown started shrinking.
But what happened was, more
Chinatowns started to open up
across the cities-- there's
like three in Brooklyn,
there's the huge one
in Flushing, Queens--
and the difference
is, when I was a kid,
it was really mostly
Chinese people
from Hong Kong, Taishan,
the Guangdong area of China.
And now that diversity
from all areas of China--
and then you also have a
lot of people from Southeast
Asia coming in, too.
So for me, it's really great,
because there's so much more
different food to try.
LYZELLE CARREON:
What do you think
are some of the biggest
challenges our communities are
facing at the moment?
CHRIS CHEUNG: Well, obviously
in today's political climate,
the immigrant journey seems
to be a little bit tougher
and there's lot more
challenges to face.
It's really just about
chasing the American dream.
I remember when I was
a kid and my mother--
we were poor and just
trying to make ends meet.
The longer you're here, the
more generations you're here,
it seems to get a
little bit better
and you seem to have a little
bit more of a advantage.
So I think education
will help that and just
putting your head down
and working hard also
goes a long way too.
LYZELLE CARREON: I think
we can all attest to that.
CHRIS CHEUNG: Yeah.
LYZELLE CARREON:
But where do you
see the community going next?
CHRIS CHEUNG: Well, you know,
bigger, better, more diversity.
A more stronger voice.
And I think that in the case of
the Asian community in general,
being on a more united
front would definitely help.
It seems like, this
Thai community,
this Chinese community,
there is Korean community,
and they all have
their own agendas,
but if you take
a couple of steps
back and kind of look at the
picture through a wider angle,
being more united because a
lot of the people who are not
on the Asian side tend
to look at Asians--
hence the word Asia, right?
So I used to hate the word
Asian food, or Asian cuisine,
because, really, there
is no Asian cuisine--
Korean food is
definitely different
than Thai; Thai is definitely
different from Chinese--
you get tend to
put into one group.
It's good to put that
perception-- make that lemons
into lemonade, and try to
be more in a united front,
because we all kind of have
the same concerns trying to be
successful in this country.
LYZELLE CARREON: Those
are great points, I think.
We would like to
know, what do you
think Google could do
to help the advancement
of the community
and all the things
that you mentioned
about united front?
CHRIS CHEUNG: Yeah, so I
got a good one for that.
Checking out the Google
Translator, right?
So if the Google
Translator can be developed
to where it hits
a home run 100%,
I think, especially with the
tonal languages, which Chinese
definitely is, it would be one
language for the whole world,
but we all still get to
keep our cultural identity.
And I think that that would be
a game changer for the world
if that was happen.
LYZELLE CARREON: Does anyone
work on Google Translator
know anyone?
Know anyone that does?
OK.
Now let's open up the floor
to see if the audience has
any questions.
There's a mic there.
I can also hand my
mic over if anyone
has any questions for Chris?
AUDIENCE: Hello,
thank you for coming.
I have two questions.
So one of my questions is, how
do you get inspired new food?
How do you-- and where
do you get inspiration
to come up with new menu?
Second question was,
I think you briefly
mentioned that you went
to the Museum of Chinese--
CHRIS CHEUNG: Yeah, the
Museum of Chinese in America.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, Museum
of Chinese in America,
and then you have a
panel discussion--
I'm just curious about
what you discussed--
and you briefly
mentioned that it
was about dealing with the
perception of the Asian
Americans?
And I was just
curious, like, what
aspect you were trying
to elaborate on?
CHRIS CHEUNG: OK.
Well, first question
about inspiration.
So when your
creative inspiration
can come from anywhere.
You go out to eat and
you try different things
and you can be inspired by that.
Travel's another way.
But sometimes, you're
just like laying
in bed trying to get
to sleep and this idea
pops in your head.
Sometimes you're
working on a dish
and you really trying to
get that last component,
and you can go for days
trying to figure it out.
And then one thing
pops and then it
just kind of just
overflows from there,
almost like the quarter
machine in Las Vegas
where you just dropped that
quarter and all of them
start spilling out.
So who knows where
it comes from?
I don't know, but I'm so
glad that it does come.
And then what we talked
about in the Asian Food
Mafia in the Museum
of Chinese in America.
So it was a lot about
sigmas in the beginning.
About fighting a
lot of the stigmas
that Asian food used to face.
MSG was one of them.
I got to say, there
was a lot of racism
back in the '60s and '70s
when it came to especially
Chinese food, and I
think a lot of that
had to do with Chinese
food all of a sudden
becoming popular and
taking up pieces of the pie
from other types of restaurants.
And there was a backlash
towards it and some propaganda.
And some of it we
did to ourselves.
The MSG thing, there was a
lot of Chinese restaurants--
you'd have mom and pop
and there wasn't really
enough chefs to go around, so
your uncle would cook the food
and he wouldn't really know
too much about cooking,
so he knew that putting this
powder in made it taste better,
but he would probably misuse it.
But really, taking that
and making a whole movement
against an Asian ingredient
which is so widely used in Asia
would be taking it a
little bit too far,
so there was a lot of those
things that we had to overcome.
Presently-- we also talked
about the present stigmas.
And right now, food in
America is treated with--
especially with the
higher end chefs--
with a very big emphasis on
the quality of ingredients.
And those ingredients
don't come cheap.
But when an Asian restaurant
uses those same ingredients,
It's so much harder for them
to demand the same price
point on their menu because
of the stigma of Asian food
being so much lower priced
than many other cuisines.
So the chefs that are trying
their hardest to be creative
and using those
great ingredients
can't make any money on it.
So that was a big thing.
And then as the future
goes on, how are we
going to overcome a
lot of these hurdles
and how we're going
to show a stronger
voice in the quality of
what we want to cook?
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
And by the way, I really
like that cucumber salad.
CHRIS CHEUNG: Oh, thank you.
Appreciate it.
Hi you doing?
AUDIENCE: I want back to the
first question because I was--
and a very practical question.
You talked about
getting inspiration
by sampling different
restaurants,
and I love exploring different
neighborhoods in New York.
Recently, for example,
I've been hearing
a lot about College Point.
Where do you like to go
and what are some places
that you've stumbled across
that you might recommend?
CHRIS CHEUNG:
Well, in New York--
so I've spent a lot of
time in Nashville, so it's
funny to get inspired by
a whole different food
scene in a whole
different city and see
the differences in cooking.
In New York, you can go to
any of the three Chinatowns
and get little gems
in the neighborhood.
So Chinatown in Manhattan
is rapidly changing.
So it used to be
all Cantonese food,
and now you're going to get a
big influx of Fuzhounese food,
which I haven't
even fully explored,
but it's a totally
different cuisine,
and so it changes
your perception
of what Chinese food is.
So much so, like, I grew
up on Cantonese food,
that's all I knew as
far as Chinese food.
I get customers who
come in on a daily basis
and say, oh, Chinese
food's too spicy.
And I'm like, I got to think
for a second, I'm like,
wow, Szechuan food
became that big
that there are
people who have never
had any Chinese food
besides Szechuan food,
and that kind of blows my mind.
With that being said,
there's some really great
Szechuan restaurants out there.
A couple in Queens, in Flushing.
One called Nan Xiang who does
really great soup dumplings.
Not Szechuan, but
Dumpling Galaxy
is another one that has
been big in the press.
And I've met Helen
at couple events
and her dumplings are
pretty much spot on.
You can go into any
of the Chinatowns--
the Chinatown in
Brooklyn is very
reminiscent of the Chinatown
in Manhattan 20 years ago,
and so there's some really
good barbecue joints there.
And you really kind of
got to go to each one
and check them out--
forget Yelp for now.
Spend some time, hang out,
pick a nice spring day,
go hungry, and really--
Chinese food in Chinatown
is pretty cheap,
there's not really that
big of an investment.
So you can, for your 30 or 40
bucks, you can eat all day.
AUDIENCE: So one quick
question followup.
For the barbecue
restaurant you mentioned,
I assume it's somewhere
around 8th Avenue,
do you know the name?
CHRIS CHEUNG: There was
one barbecue restaurant
that I've been going to
which is pretty good.
They have a few locations.
They also do a type of
cooking for Bok Choy, which
is basically cooking
in the clay pot.
It's King's Kitchen, and they
have an outlet in 8th Avenue
and they have an outlet in
Fort Hamilton Parkway, which
is a few blocks down
from 8th Avenue.
And I've been pretty impressed
with what they've been doing,
so look up King's Kitchen.
They have barbecue and
clay pot cooking, which
is really, really cool stuff.
You'll enjoy it.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
CHRIS CHEUNG: You're welcome.
LYZELLE CARREON: You're going
to have to share those with me.
I hope you write them down.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Chris.
Thanks so much for coming.
CHRIS CHEUNG: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I have two questions.
One, what is some
advice you would
give to someone who's trying
to start their own business?
Doesn't have to be a restaurant.
Any business.
CHRIS CHEUNG: Well,
OK, so one thing
is be grounded, be
balanced, because starting
your own business and an
incredibly difficult thing,
and like I said,
especially in New York,
it's even more
difficult, especially
if you're doing it
from the retail point.
You know, renting a space in
New York can be very harrowing--
you need a lawyer,
you need a broker--
and both those
positions cost money.
So you're going to spend money.
From the restaurant side is--
one big advice I
have is, you need
to be aware of a
realistic budget.
So if you think that
it's going to cost you
$100,000 to open the store,
it's going to cost $200,000.
Do not open your doors
spending all your money.
You need to open your doors
with a big cushion, because--
and I've done this before, so
you think you open your doors
and you're going to be
busy right off the bat?
A lot of times that
doesn't happen.
The food press helps
you and a name helps you
and you can bring
those people in,
but sometimes you'll
go three weeks,
a month before
things start to look
more realistic to the
numbers that you projected.
If you can't survive
that month, you're
already going to be
behind your bills,
and that's the call of
doom for businesses,
especially because
nobody's going
to help you in your first year.
So then you have to find
another investor, which
means that your equity is now
less than what you want it to.
You're not making any money
for the first couple of years.
And you're working harder than
you've ever done to just get
your head above water.
So not to put a dark edge
on opening a business,
because when you're successful,
there's nothing better,
but You have to get there.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
Great tips.
And Now my next question was,
what made you choose Nashville?
CHRIS CHEUNG: So I didn't choose
Nashville, Nashville chose me.
Monique Chauhan, who is
a Food Network celebrity
chef, I worked with her on
the Sabra Recipe Challenge,
which was a Food Network--
Sabra, which makes the
hummus, the company that
makes the hummus spreads, they
did an internet cooking show
and we were chosen for
it, so I got to know her
on the set of that show.
And afterwards-- and I
used the rib her, too,
because I was always
a restaurant guy
and she was pursuing a career
in television at the time
and I was like, it's
so much cooler just
to have your own restaurant
and running your restaurant
and to be on TV.
You get to cook and
things like that.
So what she did was she
went down to Nashville
and she opened up, like, four.
And one of them
was a Chinese one
and she needed a
chef to run that,
and so she made me a partner
and she offered me a deal
and it was a pretty good deal,
so I said, what the hell.
So now I have a
restaurant down there.
AUDIENCE: Cool!
And what's the name
of the restaurant?
CHRIS CHEUNG: It's
called Tansuo.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And opens later this--
CHRIS CHEUNG: No,
it's already opened.
It opened-- it's about
three weeks old now.
AUDIENCE: Well congratulations.
CHRIS CHEUNG: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hey, Chris,
thanks for coming.
I've been to the East
Winds Snack Shop on a date,
it was really good.
CHRIS CHEUNG: Thanks, man!
AUDIENCE: Great experience.
So you briefly mentioned that
it is pretty hard to open
a restaurant in New York City.
Did you ever have like
that oh shit moment like,
I might not make it.
Or like a moment of crisis?
CHRIS CHEUNG: I
have that every day.
Every single day.
Every single day you
worry about what the food
quality, you worry
about your employees,
you worry about the business--
you're worrying on
a constant basis.
It's like having a kid.
You It's so many moving parts.
Is the walk in up
the temperature?
Is my dishwasher coming in late?
And there's so many things
to handle at every twist
and turn, you really--
as the older I got,
I've had to find ways
to deal with stress better.
I gotta tell you.
So you take the good
days when you have them
and you enjoy them, and
you put your head down you
knock out every problem
as they come along.
It's managing crises when
you own your own business,
especially a restaurant.
AUDIENCE: Surely at some
point the number of crises
starts to normalize.
CHRIS CHEUNG: No, what it
becomes is becomes normal.
And you just kind of take it
without really much emotion,
and, you know, call the
repair guy, pay the money,
hire the new cook, fire the
old one for not showing up,
things like that.
And you have to
wear a lot of hats
and you have to be able to be
calm under pressure and figure
things out as you go and try to
figure things out in the least
expensive way possible.
Hey, [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Hey, Chris.
So I have two questions.
The first one is,
what do you think
about the integrated
tipping system that's
coming through a
lot of restaurant--
maybe not a lot-- some
restaurants in New York?
I'll start with that.
CHRIS CHEUNG: All right,
so yeah, I don't get it.
I'm the back of the house guy.
I'm a chef, but I
was always a chef,
I was a cook for many years.
And yeah, it really
does suck to--
let's say, take Jean-George.
For Jean-George, I
worked with Jean-George
and I worked about
100 hours a week.
The shift was come in at
9:00 and leave at 6:00.
I'd come in at 6:30 and leave
at 9:30 or 10:00 at night just
to get my stuff done.
And I got paid about
$250 a week for that job.
And it really sucked
to watch waiters
leave making $500 a night.
But I see a lot of talk about
we have to take the tipping away
and pay the back of the
house-- which is great,
because I'm a back
of the house guy--
and then raise your prices
on the menu to justify that.
I don't see why you have
to take tipping away.
If you're going to raise
the prices on the menu,
make it simple, just raise
the prices on the menu.
Somebody has got to pay for
the higher increase of labor.
There's a big push to
make the minimum wage $15,
and that's for your
lowest paid employees,
so that's basically for the guy
who cleans the restaurant, $15.
Cooks will probably
make $18 an hour.
Which is great, everybody
should get a fair wage,
but you where that money's
coming from, right?
That doesn't come
out of the business.
The profit margins
for restaurants are,
if you don't know,
are tremendously low.
If you're making 20%,
you're doing really good.
Sometimes you're just
doing it on to break even.
So for restaurants that
are struggling and have
to pay that, the menu prices
are going to go up eventually.
The restaurant world
is resisting that now.
Because everybody's afraid.
It's a tough market.
But eventually,
you're not even going
to blink at a $25 hamburger.
That's just how
it's going to be.
AUDIENCE: Right.
I need a promotion.
[LAUGHS] The next question
is, you've worked out of a lot
of really incredible
restaurants--
Jean-George's, a few
others-- so I'm curious,
who was one chef that you worked
with that you really respected
or maybe just something that
they did that you found just--
like maybe you do it--
you find kind of integrating
into your day to day?
CHRIS CHEUNG: Yeah.
There's been a lot of chefs
that helped me in my career
in different aspects.
So I worked for Jean-George
and I worked for Nobu,
and Jean-George was great
because the name was great,
and I, in his
kitchen especially,
at Jean-George's,
learning the discipline
of cooking four-star
French cuisine,
you really got to immerse
yourself in that world.
When you work at a four
star restaurant, four star
"New York Times" restaurant,
which probably equates
to three star Michelin or two
star Michelin here in America,
it's very much like working
in the very strict confines
of a French restaurant.
You gotta give yourself
to that discipline.
You're not going to see family,
you're not going to go out
and party, you're not
going to see your friends
on the weekend, you basically
work that 100, 110 hours a week
and just concentrate on cooking.
And that's what that gave me.
So basically, I learned
to be really attached
to the craft of what cooking is.
Nobu, on the other hand, I
was a young cook at Nobu,
and he let me
experiment with dishes
that a young cook would have
no place experimenting with
and get stuff on the menu.
And so he was integral for
sparking a creative edge in me
as well.
I worked for James Chu, who was
the chef at Typhoon Brewery.
He's not as well
known as those, chefs
but he really taught me how to
break down flavors on my palate
as we ate.
His whole thing was the
five flavors of food,
which was spicy, sour,
sweet, salty, bitter,
and how to discern
that as you eat.
And so that was very integral.
So each chef that
you learn under,
you'll learn under
different things.
As I got higher up the ladder, I
learned under a Dim Sum master.
And he just taught me
techniques of Chinese food
and recipes of Chinese
food that I wouldn't
have learned anywhere else.
And that was really an important
part of my learning process
as well.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
CHRIS CHEUNG: You're welcome.
How are you?
AUDIENCE: Hey, Chris.
Thanks for coming.
So I was wondering
what's the best
way to market your business?
Do you use AdWords?
CHRIS CHEUNG: Let's see,
how do I answer that one?
No, but send me an email
and I'll check it out.
The world is expanded
and contracted
as far as marketing a business
and special restaurants, right?
Like I said, the city makes it
difficult. You know, the best--
the easiest way for restaurants
that-- a neighborhood
restaurant-- to
market themselves,
was to pass flyers
throughout all the houses
that are near you on
your block, right?
They took that away.
They fine you now if
you do that, right?
So it's kind of illegal or
we're not permitted anymore,
which is really tough, right?
Because you still see
the market [INAUDIBLE].
The big companies can do
it because they either
get the allowance
to do it or they can
afford to pay the fines, right?
So with that taken away,
it's really, really tough
for a restaurant to
get their name out.
But you have social media now.
And social media is a big
part of getting the word out
and getting people to
see what you are all
about with the pictures
and just saying things
that you want people to
know about your place.
So that helps a lot.
The press, food press,
for operators like me
are extremely important.
As a chef, you live and die
by what a reviewer says.
And you got to take the good
with the bad, knock on wood.
I've had my share
of good, so that's
one of the special
things that make
New York a really cool food city
to get that, but not everybody
gets that.
So the climb is tough and
really, sometimes quality
and just doing the right
thing isn't enough.
You really got to
have other resources.
Anything that will help
you in an inexpensive way,
you have to explore.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
CHRIS CHEUNG: Thanks.
Everybody good?
LYZELLE CARREON: Do we
have any other questions?
I guess that's it--
oh, one more.
AUDIENCE: First of
all, I'm from Lawrence.
My teammate, we both were for
AdWords and ask the question.
[LAUGHTER] The first one
is more of the comment
about what you said
about the Asian, kind
of umbrella of term, the Asian.
There was actually a great
panel a couple weeks--
I don't know if other
people watched--
on kind of diversity, and
there were a Sikh activist
and a Korean blogger and I
think a [INAUDIBLE] activist?
Quite a few diverse--
the bulk of all Asian
representatives,
and the Korean
blogger was great.
And he was saying--
he was kind of the
same thing, right?
Because Asian is so
not all Asian talk--
oh, Asian community, but it's
really so diverse within Asia.
But the funny thing
that he said is
that, one thing that
kind of seem to unite,
where even like--
distinguish Asian is food!
We eat so diverse,
different food.
But that may be one thing
that unites us, right?
CHRIS CHEUNG: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Or something.
So I think you as a great
Chinese chef, or Asian chef--
I don't really think
that [INAUDIBLE]
brand yourself as Asian.
CHRIS CHEUNG: I cooked
a lot of Thai food,
I cooked a lot of Japanese food,
but the last few years I've
really immersed myself
into Chinese food,
so I kind of refer to
myself as a Chinese chef.
But I am familiar, very
familiar with other types
of Asian cooking.
And again, it's a word
that, for a lot of years,
it kind of bothered
me a little bit.
We don't refer to European
cooking as European cooking,
it's French or Italian.
And so I struggled with that.
I haven't-- and I still use the
term because it's widely used
in general, and it does have
some good to it as well.
But I do struggle with that.
As part of an identity, you
want, as a Chinese person,
you don't want to
really be referred
to as Asian, you want to
be referred to as Chinese,
and I'm sure if you're
Korean or you Japanese
or you're Indian or--
you want the same thing.
But on the other hand, the
perception of it as a tool
can be very beneficial.
So yeah, it's a struggle,
at least for me,
to kind of come to
terms with that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] And by
the way, how are you branding
your new Nashville restaurant?
CHRIS CHEUNG: Yeah.
So again, I brand it as a--
when I'm approached, I say
it's a Chinese restaurant.
Nashville actually
happens to be publicly--
they publicly say they
need better Chinese food
in the city, from everywhere
from the mayor to the cab
drivers to everybody,
it's amazing.
But their perception
is also rooted
in having Asian
eateries in town.
But it's a little
bit different there
because they don't have a big
Asian community, so they're
accepting of pretty much
any good quality Asian food
that they can get.
Hopefully I've given them
something that they want.
So far, so good.
AUDIENCE: All right,
another question.
Oh, actually, sorry, forgot
to thank you for coming.
And so this question is--
maybe more like
a trick question.
So you mention that your East
Wind is only three block away,
right?
So it's probably easy
for you to commute.
Are there days when you just
feel like, oh, I'm going there
again, I'm making
the same dumpling,
say you whatever, that maybe
I should do something else.
I mean, you actually
opened your new restaurant.
And that kind
relates to us, right?
We're engineers and
our thing or whatever.
And we have to get out and
commute to our-- today, it's
great right?
Because we get to eat
your bao and salad,
that really get me up--
but how do you get
by the daily grind?
CHRIS CHEUNG: Well,
it's each to his own.
The daily grind, everybody
has their daily grind, right?
Some days are
better than others.
Good cooking is
rooted in repetition,
so some days you will
take the practice
and some days you look
forward to holding a craft
and trying to do better
than the day before.
Sometimes that you've had
a bad day the day before,
but in the restaurant
business, a bad day
means you get to do it again the
next day and try even harder.
So you have that as a
motivational tool for you.
But there are some days, whole
10 degree day in February,
you've got to get out
there early to shovel snow
before you actually
start cooking.
Or 98 degrees in August where
basically the last thing
you want to do is leave your
air conditioned bedroom.
But there were a lot
of benefits to being
successful in the
restaurant business.
You get to do other projects,
you get to do events,
you get to come to Google and
hang out and talk and talk
shop and things like that.
So mixing it up is
always good and getting
a little bit of recognition for
some hard work is always good.
But knowing that you always have
to go back and cook the food--
you got to make the doughnuts--
is very important.
You can't lose
sight of what you've
done the years before
for your whole career,
and that basically was going
into work the very next day.
My business is a
six day work week.
Now, for me, it's a
seven day work week.
It's 12 hours a day minimum.
It's working on Christmas,
it's working on Thanksgiving,
so it's missing all the weddings
and all the birthday parties.
So you have to really be
dedicated to your craft to--
I haven't missed that.
I come home to a quiet house.
My kids and wife
are already sleeping
by the time I get home.
So it's kind of one
of those things.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
I guess I should
stay in Google, then.
It's too hard.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
CHRIS CHEUNG: Hey, how are you?
AUDIENCE: Thanks
again for coming in.
CHRIS CHEUNG: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: So we have Anthony
Bourdain opening his market
two blocks from us here,
which is an interesting trend,
and that's the basis
of my question.
Do you think these markets
mean the future trend
within the industry,
specifically
for Asian restaurants?
Or, if you step forward
five, 10 years from now,
what is the restaurant
scene, the Asian restaurant
scene in this area?
CHRIS CHEUNG: It's a--
that's a pretty loaded
question, because I
think that on the base of it,
the food court and food stalls
are inspired from a lot of
what we see outside of America.
They're very popular in Europe,
they're very also very popular
in all around Asia-- the
night markets in Asia--
and they kind of
follow on those things
and they're immensely
popular there.
If we can get the
operation to represent
what the American crowd
would accept here as well
and it's done right--
those places can be very
disorganized and very crazy,
and some of the regulations,
especially in this city,
probably won't allow that
much chaos to happen,
so there has to be a little
bit of a middle ground.
You kind of got to take that
[INAUDIBLE] of the woods
so that there's--
As real estate in New York
becomes way more and more
expensive and smaller guys with
a lot of creative bones in them
can't open restaurants,
especially in Manhattan--
they have to go to Queens,
they have to go to Brooklyn--
and if there is
opportunities for them
to do it with less
money, those food stalls
are going to become very
important for guys like that,
especially me.
And the opportunities become a
little bit more easier to have.
And it's going to promote a lot
of chefs to do better things.
And then though, on
the other side of it,
it still will perpetuate the
perception of Asian food being
cheap, because I don't think
many people are going to want--
food stores aren't
usually cheap,
but they're not
super expense and you
can't get fine dining
out of them either,
and that's one of the areas
that a lot of Asian chefs
and restaurants, especially
in New York and in America,
haven't been able to be
successful in the fine dining
level.
That's not going to
help that part too much.
So it just depends on kind
of where you're looking at.
And I think most of the
smaller mom and pop businesses
are willing to sacrifice
that in an effort to be
successful in the business end.
AUDIENCE: Yeah it
seems if you just
remove a lot of
the administration,
it's like working for one
the startup [INAUDIBLE]
or something, right?
Where location is taken
care of, a lot overhead
is taken care of, you can
focus more on the craft.
CHRIS CHEUNG:
Yeah, but everybody
takes their piece
of the pie, right?
So I've been in
a couple of deals
with a couple of food stalls
and a lot the space is shared.
The refrigerator.
Refrigeration is shared.
The work spaces are shared.
And what I'm going
to find interesting,
especially on the
Bourdain food stall,
is he doesn't just
have people sharing,
he has people from
different countries
that don't speak
the same language--
that aren't from here--
all sharing the
same common areas.
And I have a kitchen, and when
my saute cook and my wok cook
can't fit the ingredients
in the same area in the wok
and it comes close to blows.
And so when they're
all going to have
to learn how to share and
then be up to standards
and sanitary things and
reporting and all that stuff,
he has a big hurdle to overcome
on something like that,
I believe.
AUDIENCE: That's a
great perspective.
Thank you.
CHRIS CHEUNG: Yeah, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Same topic, but I
know DaDong has just opened,
the Peking duck place,
upscale, in Bryant Park?
CHRIS CHEUNG: Yes, yes, yes.
AUDIENCE: Do you
think that will impact
the perception of Asian food?
I can't imagine that's
going to be inexpensive.
CHRIS CHEUNG: No, I don't
think it's going to be--
I know the guy.
I've heard of the guy and
I know some of the deals
that he's been trying.
He wanted that real
estate for free.
He wanted that rent free
because it's his name.
I'm not sure if
he got that deal,
but he's got a pretty good
sweetheart deal for the Bryant
Park location.
It may.
I think it will, but
it will be tempered.
I don't think it's
going to carry the torch
to make Chinese restaurants
one or two Michelin
star for the rest of the
chefs that want to come here.
New York is a funny place.
When people from
outside New York
think off the bat that they're
going to have an automatic hit,
sometimes it doesn't
work out for them.
I wish him all the best.
He has a really,
really good reputation.
If he can replicate
what he does in Hong
Kong and the other
places in the world--
I think he has
Australia, and I think
he has another place too--
if he can do that in
New York successfully--
and again, he's going
to fight the same stigma
as everybody else is.
I don't see, because of
his name and reputation,
I think he still gonna have
to fight through some of that.
So it's a wait and
see kind of thing.
I think it's going
to have to be organic
and it's going to take time.
But the wheels are
turning already.
We are a lot farther from
the starting point where
we were 20 years ago, so
hopefully in five years
we can make another
big leap as well.
LYZELLE CARREON:
I think that's all
the time we have for questions.
Thank you so much,
Chris for being here
and for answering
all our questions!
CHRIS CHEUNG: I had a
blast, that was really cool!
[APPLAUSE]